seit zwei jahren fehlt von der kühlbox
jede spur und jetzt soll der künstler
für tot erklärt werden bei mir im studio
ist jetzt bernd peters hallo bernd kam
diese nachricht überraschend schon ein
bisschen also es gibt diese regel für
auf see verschollene personen dass sie
nach sechs monaten für tot erklärt
werden können
aber die mietwohnung ist natürlich dann
auf kann jetzt gibt es eben den antrag
und den bearbeitet das amtsgerichts
passau und die haben wiederum eine
anzeige geschaltet dass sich daniel
küblböck innerhalb der nächsten wochen
melden soll
tut er das nicht würden sie ihnen dann
für tot erklären und was sagt sein vater
dazu oder auch seine ganze familie
ja der ist halt aus allen wolken
gefallen und das ist auch das
überraschendste an dieser ganzen
geschichte weil das amtsgericht passau
ist offenbar nicht für nötig befunden
hat ihn vorher mal zu fragen
und da muss man ja zumindest ausleihen
sicht kann man sich daher nur wundern
warum dann nicht der nächste angehörige
zumindest mal gefragt wird es gibt
diesen antrag der von einer gmbh
gestellt wurde die sich wohl in
nachfolge von daniel küblböck sehen
dahinter soll auch ein verwandter stehen
aber wohl nicht so ein enger verwandter
wie der vater
und da fragt man sich ja schon
warum wurde nicht gefragt das hat er uns
auch gesagt und er regt sich dann
natürlich darüber auf dass sie so eine
anzeige schalten ohne ihnen da überhaupt
mal zu kontaktieren und warum haben
manche fans immer noch die hoffnung dass
erlebt ja das ist natürlich ein bisschen
krude theorie aber es passiert
tatsächlich immer mal wieder was auf dem
obwohl auch früher offiziellen instagram
account von von daniel küblböck da
werden kommentare gelöscht
da tauchen plötzlich irgendwelche fotos
auf und daraus konstruieren dann fans
natürlich in der hoffnung weil so lange
sein tod nicht nachgewiesen wird wird es
wahrscheinlich auch immer die hoffnung
geben
in sämtlichen solcher fälle aber diese
hoffnung ist natürlich sehr sehr gering
gewesen